[Music]
oh my god it is absolutely stunningly
beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
I've just been here a few hours walking
these streets
wide wide boulevards beautiful parks
real expansive landscapes the history
here is quite crazy pre-world War two
mints had a population of 300,000 people
Hitler came in Operation Barbarossa
within a few days took over the city by
the end of World War two the city's
population was 50,000 people eighty
percent of the city was destroyed so it
was built it was built from the ground
up basically by Stalin so far I can say
Minsk is an extreme place look at this
sidewalk bit extreme why'd nobody on it
the architecture it's either it's either
you love that stuff you absolutely love
it or you hate it I absolutely love it I
think it's so creative and interesting
and then all this infrastructure is just
beautiful it's set up and where do you
see granite on just the edge of a park
unbelievable craftsmanship they lay the
bricks in there I'm just walking down a
normal sidewalk so behind me you have
that modern stuff in front is this I
think Sylvia apartment relic and then we
have this what looks to be an old town
ahead a lot of bike paths people running
working out
my first KFC experience a very special
one
Minsk style what adds to the craziness
of the scene is the music this sort of
fluffy suburbia music while this
situations above it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
looks like an art district so you have
all these old warehouse buildings that
have been obviously creatively painted
and I don't know what's going on here
but it goes on for some ways
this is moderate Modern Art inside here
it's relatively new they've been putting
these murals up and it's sort of the
young hipster yoga vegan healthy food
crowd it seems like this is what's so
cool about travel is just stumbling upon
the surprises but I'm doing my best here
you guys to show you help you feel this
place and not just take you down the
standard tourist room wow what a shot
that's a shot that is so interesting we
have some it's called surrealism and
then Lenin that was just in Bishkek and
curious Stan and they had Lenin statues
everywhere and I asked him why because
in most Soviet republics they take him
down and I was told you know a very
simple obvious end answer it's our
history it's it's you know what we went
through as a country why would you take
the statues down
so I'm guessing that's the same
yeah here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the most interesting of these stops got
a season let in
[Music]
one area the Soviet Union really did get
it right was making these public places
accessible and beautiful so that behind
me is the Opera House it's right near
the center you have these these
expansive and beautiful laid out parks
you have a very beautiful Metro and so
the places where the public could spend
time together we're done
from what I can see really well and
that's nice I mean that's what's special
about having a city is to bring everyone
together into nice places quite often in
new cities especially new western themed
cities well everyone's separated and
pulled apart and so you don't have that
that collective feel you get some time
off and you want to go to the center you
want to go to the park you want to go to
the Opera House because these are the
nicest places to hang out in the city
definitely a cool aspect of what the
Soviets tried to create it's not all
negative like we like to think of it as
it was all one big failure but they they
got some things right and I will say
this is definitely one of them
[Music]
Looby Mina Ruby
shot him
module in your Seattle Tasha guy
[Music]
issues I Yahoo
[Music]
you live in your beer you're beaming I
do feel you baby
baby
women yalla beer
game I mean you know what I mean
[Music]
yeah
yeah
lupa mean yahoo bill
[Music]
[Music]
I find there to be a bit of an irony in
the fact that a place like Minsk Belarus
always gets put down in the West at
least and well people only see political
context or the flashpoints that the
media likes to cover but the reality is
this place is most likely cleaner and
nicer than where you're from there's
some exceptions out there perhaps Uruk
or Tokyo but as far as a city just to be
curious in and walk around and find all
these little nooks and crannies and
amazing sites Minsk is it's a very
creative place maybe not for the locals
they're used to a buffer from an
outsider's perspective it's got a lot of
different elements going on here end of
the day people are cool super cool I
don't feel it's an aggressive culture
people are open easy to talk to
yeah another one of those perception
versus reality realities look it's got
its bad sides too for sure everywhere
does but as far as being a tourist and
visiting this place it's absolutely
fantastic I'm trying to figure out all
these hammer and sickles like these
communist signs everywhere like in the
Metro the Lenin statues what do you
think when you see all that stuff like
what do young people think
when they see that stuff usually you
know because I live here and I can't say
that it's good bad I like to write like
it for me it's ok for me it's normal
usual - so are the cops they're very
strong here right yeah yeah
because in Ukraine I from what I've seen
the cops seem quite passive here they're
not passive we have here such order and
even people who are dangerous before now
they don't touch anybody this is what's
so cool about mins is you're like near
that very heavy architecture and then in
one of these buildings is this
environment styles so next cool
courtyard in here the courtyard in this
very calm
zone maybe you want to go to work here
welcome to Valerie's maybe you move do
you know um Lee Harvey Oswald did that
the guy that killed John F Kennedy lived
here did you know that he like renounced
his US citizenship I heard and lived in
Minsk for a few years I think he had a
factory job so I don't want to do that
because look what happened to him
because he moved back to the United
States and then killed JFK the toilet is
the bar
our toilet Minsk style extreme so
there's a pull one I tell you marry you
okay
something exactly
they've escaped me huh team party group
at Oh a DHS okay this is what we're
talking about the first time in there I
wouldn't have dared to put my camera up
they would have like smashed it
you know they look so so stoic so
serious so pissed off and then it's like
you just gotta say one or two things and
you open them up and they're so cool and
warm I think you can help 'full
lovely I like it that way because you
have to earn your smiles you have to
like nobody's just gonna give it to you
but the other dudes gonna [ __ ] you
it's just fully authentic our driver
here Demetri it's got an interesting
style
Cheeta on the back full military uniform
called a cool guy
[Music]
[Music]
you
it's so modern and nice here and it's a
mystery to me because I was told the
average salary is four hundred and fifty
dollars and so you have all these new
buildings you have these brand new
apartment blocks and there are a lot of
them and they're nice something doesn't
add up and as a tourist you never really
know what's going on actually I can see
things that locals can't see in here and
locals can see and hear things that I
can't that I would never know I was born
here and I like that vegan places are
opening and that's really cool your
vegan yes it's becoming more popular
here cool
valina you're awesome Thank You YouTube
so that's the entryway to the Metro we
have beautiful park there looks like a
theater
I'm guessing a government building
entry wyndham metro and then look at
this long street full of restaurants
cafes but all in this grand
Nisha's I yeah
inaudible
[Music]
I love you
[Music]
that's my Minsk story guys three and a
half days in this beautiful city really
a fantastic place different than
anything else I've experienced and if
you're thinking of coming here you want
something different and interesting
Minsk is definitely one of those places
[Music]
luminol ubi
Sharkey
not you
[Music]